yeah so what's going on here everybody's
making a big stink about this
yeah so trucker carlson so basically
it's difficult to get an actual number
yeah but it seems like there's a couple
thousand truckers and then like maybe
like 50 to 60 000 like people in ottawa
has the media made them racist yet or
yeah oh they have okay just making sure
because that will happen yeah trudeau
did the same thing like he said in a
statement that like most people that are
against the mandates are more likely to
be racist more likely to be a part of
neo-nazi groups of course listen if
black people protest
they're violent if white people protest
their races this is just the media spin
if black people protest they will put
what is it called the cointelpro [ __ ]
they'll throw people in there
to break [ __ ] windows start the
looting light the buildings on fire to
make the black protests look dangerous
and [ __ ] violent so we could stop the
black protest if white people protest it
doesn't matter what they're [ __ ] pro
they are racist there's some skinheads
guaranteed they're i even saw one thing
pop up like there was at least one
confederate flag
at least one two what kind of title is
it how many did you see
you know what i mean and also is that
the white coin tell pro are they trying
to discredit the movement by just
throwing in the racist [ __ ] there yeah
it's the same [ __ ] play every single
time so is it that obvious this is a
tweet that was put out by someone
basically saying that like the protest
is cancerous and that all these people
are like racist and fascists so they
have this person wearing like an
infowars jacket they got this person in
like a confederate flag
uh these people i forgot his name he's
like the canadian runner dude terry yeah
yeah yeah with one leg harry fox or
something i forget
30 for 30 on him yeah that was great i
can't remember his name but he's like a
canadian hero that everyone loves and
they claim that they deface the statue
you want to know something interesting
about that there was actually a really
cool clip i saw so he had a statue and
they put
obviously some stuff on the statue and
this is the most canadian thing ever
the protesters cleaned up after their
protests and you see people wiping down
his statue removing any garbage from it
removing any like
stickers or things they put on it like
literally spit shining the statue right
and i was like that's fire bro like it
ain't about this dude you know this
guy's a canadian hero for what he did
yeah and they're not gonna just leave
the whole place in disarray so it looked
like the defacement that they did was
they put like a flag as like a cape on
them and then like another canadian flag
and then a free manitoba
thing in his hand yeah and then this is
the one that people are pointing out the
most so it's like the don't tread on me
flag nazi flag
trump flag and then canadian flag yeah
and this is the only picture of this
person that's been circulated but a lot
of people have been passing around
basically to say like the protest is
neo-nazis racist yeah you shut it down
make it radioactive it's the same
playbook every single time
it's the same playbook every single and
also like if those are real people are
there that are there
[ __ ] you dude
dude like why can you not make this
about you for one second
like first of all if you have a nazi
flag you should like these mandates
you should like snitch on your neighbor
you should be there supporting right you
have a dictator telling you when you can
go outside and when you can't this is
everything you dream why are you
protesting if you're a nazi yeah right
you should not be here this is not for
you yeah you like what's going on in
canada if you're a nazi
true or false yeah so it came on the
tales of like the vax mandate for
truckers basically that they have to be
federal workers right all federal
workers for all i thought it was
truckers specifically going to the u.s
and coming back yeah well no they were
added to it but for all federal workers
in canada and that's why they went to
ottawa yeah yeah and so basically but
the truckers were sort of like uh
catalyzed because of the trucker mandate
yeah and which that's the only thing i
didn't really get like calling all the
truckers like racist and [ __ ]
considering that like the large majority
of them are like immigrants yeah yeah
like it's like also like 80 of them are
vast yeah i mean if you're in canada
like 90 percent yeah there's some crazy
numbers
with the adult population
if america wants to say you have to be
vacs across over that's on us that's not
on your government yeah that's on us so
that has nothing to do with it but if
you don't think that you should be for
that job then you're allowed to protest
that we did in america and then they uh
struck it down right i think they just
said that federal workers do not have to
correct or it's not going to be
federally mandated or it's not going to
be federally mandated like a corporation
can still do it yeah like that was like
the carhartt thing and like which i
think yeah i think that makes sense if
it but those things yeah if a business
wants it but for for federal jobs is no
longer mandated
10 o'clock today oh shucks yeah oh
shucks did you get covered convenient
huh
that's what dude what did they say uh
they were saying about biden like every
time he has to address something they
get a new pet in the white house
right every time there's something that
you actually need him to talk about it's
like distract distract distract and now
of course they can't send me to someone
in there for him to make a statement
yeah god forbid he could uh
get some covet on them he could transmit
that [ __ ] covet yeah yeah so this is
one of the pictures from like the
confederate flag truck everyone was
pointing out and it's just like alone in
the middle of the street somewhere
basically to suggest that like there's
nobody there there's just one guy from
iowa that has like iowa place like drove
up to try to like instigate either
intentionally or was like
actually a confederate like sympathizer
like southern pride person that wanted
to go to the protest yeah is iowa even
in the south
i mean
there's confederate i don't even know
where the [ __ ] is this
midwest but still i mean it's just
dude that's so funny it makes sense
being in canada yeah yeah and then
there's videos of people like kicking
the confederate flag people out and like
kicking good like the trump people out
yeah even if you did believe in all
those [ __ ] abhorrent things you can't
stomach it for one day to go support
this mass mandate thing you know that
you're gonna take away from it by do by
putting that stuff out there you know
you're gonna you know you're gonna um
what is it called you know you're gonna
create radioactivity around the movement
yeah and take away from the movement so
you must actually not really care that
much about the movement unless they tie
those things together
i guess like uh freedom
yeah but just focus on one thing if you
want to get some [ __ ] done you got to
focus on one thing at a time you want to
focus on vaccines that's what we're
focused on you want to focus on
overthrowing a government they kick that
can down the road but you know attack
stone yeah yeah so to act stone i was
talking to him this is back in the day
about this is when uh a lot of black
lives matter and like police brutality
stuff was was really starting to bubble
up this is early early stages right now
he's in he's in prison obviously
um
and he was like i don't talk about it i
go why not
you seem to be someone who really cares
like what's going on he goes they'll use
me to discredit the movement
here's this felon talking about what we
should do and they'll literally just put
the spotlight on him because it
discredits what these other incredibly
reasonable law-abiding citizens are
saying and he recognized that so he
shined a spotlight on people who can
talk about it right but he didn't mean
to be the one taking the credit right
you know i just thought that that was
like really interesting like and like
really smart yeah like he recognized
what he could do for the movement and
what he couldn't
right but he's super smart he has the
wherewithal to know those types of
things and not everybody does some of
these [ __ ] hillbillies just crossing
the border to canada yeah like a trucker
protest is interesting too because
apparently these people can stay there
for a while
like that seems like the plan is like if
trudeau is gonna be out for eight days
it's like we're gonna park on the street
and block all the city blocks around the
capitol and we're gonna live in our
trucks because you can that's right to
have those cabins and all that [ __ ] so
they're like we're just gonna wait until
either he resigns or all the mandates
are lifted like they are in england and
scandinavia and other parts of europe
that's why i'm not cancelling those um
those toronto shows
because it could happen i i really think
those toronto shows will be possible i i
do too i think were there march i think
fourth and fifth or fifth and sixth or
something like that okay and initially
they were like oh you know the the new
mandate says it has to be half capacity
by you know from uh i guess
until march 14th right so that would end
up canceling the shows we just wouldn't
have enough time to fill it but i'm like
this thing's coming down
this thing is coming down and i think
that we're gonna be at full capacity
before them i think we're gonna be able
to think about you know you're talking
about how polite canadians are like
they'll protest and clean up the statue
think about how far you got to push them
for them to reach this point yeah you
know what i mean this is
yo you want to talk about mishandling a
pandemic the back half of the pandemic
they have completely mishandled yeah
since the moment they had vaccines we
acted like they didn't they acted like
they didn't exist
vaccines took care of a lot of [ __ ] and
they were just like nope nope we're
still locked up events are canceled my
shows were cancelled hey everything shut
it down you have pushed them and pushed
them and pushed them and now again like
i said you're creating this reaction if
you think it's an overreaction they're
reacting to you yeah so you push them
here but
the majority of canadians like it that's
the crazy part to me they just
re-elected trudeau yeah they liked what
he did in the pandemic
maybe they feel pushed back now but
they had the opportunity to get him out
of here and i think they unanimously
elected him so there's not even like i
believe it's called like a coalition or
something i'm not exactly sure how their
like election process works because he
represents a group but you don't you you
vote for like the group
not him specifically and the group
elects the person yeah yeah but it's
like they you name they don't even have
anything to push back against so it's
like maybe the people of canada do want
this yeah and maybe he was right when he
said a small minority
of people are going to ottawa to push
back
but like look at the end of the day if
we believe in democracy and 51 of the
people want that [ __ ] to be completely
locked down you have zero freedom that's
what your country wants and that's what
you guys are
yeah yeah yeah it is crazy though like i
feel like maybe i'm in a bubble but like
i just don't know anyone that is
actively like yeah we should keep on
having
indoor mask mandate
to your table or like that [ __ ] all that
i don't know anyone that still wants it
i mean usually people who like how
things are happening aren't as vocal
because they're content with how things
are happening i guess like people who
are upset about it that are going to
speak they're going to be the loudest
ones that's a good point i'll even just
ask people like my friends that i find
yeah nobody's out there cheering more of
this
yeah that's true yeah but like i'll
actively ask people that i think would
give me like an
answer that i wouldn't expect and
they're all just like yeah it can go
away like it seems more passive but i
don't see anyone that's like actively
like i think we're all over the mask
[ __ ] yeah i'm sorry we're over it hovid
we're all over
like all of us there might be a few
people that like the power that it gives
them and i'm talking about like just the
power to tell someone to put on their
mask yeah like
can you put your mask over your nose oh
like dude if another person tells me to
put my [ __ ] mask over my nose
i dude i'm going to be
that will be the thing that cancels me
that would be the thing with cancer is
when they dragged me out of a plane
because i punched a flight attendant in
her [ __ ] forehead because she told me
to put my mask over my nose unbelievable
right
unbelievable you see my nose
get me another mask yeah but you notice
in first class they don't give you any
hard times no son
take it off that's elitism bro that's
the [ __ ] that annoys me it's like it's
the clash [ __ ] because like if you're in
first class they legit don't give you a
hard time you don't care i have it off
the whole time sleeping without it like
they don't care and you know what's
interesting about the first class thing
the way they kind of get around it they
feed you the whole time yeah drink you
want a watercolor exactly now
i'm drinking i'm eating i can't possibly
have this mask on
so there's like this little excuse but
you're right they don't give a [ __ ] yeah
they don't give a flying [ __ ] that's
just for thee and that's not for me
that's the consistent all like the
classic [ __ ] though like all like the
gavin newsom at the
rams game just like in the box
everyone's gotta have a mask he doesn't
have his mask on yeah
but that's on him like why are you
making rules that you can't follow
bye-bye the most vocal people on that in
california the moms now you're gonna do
that on a sunday and now my
four-year-old needs to be messed up at
school the next day outside on the
playground like they are wild
the kid mass thing i didn't understand
at first i was like why is this such a
big deal like the kids have to wear
masks actually just painful to watch it
but yeah
because i didn't watch it so it's like a
kid yeah you just put a [ __ ] hat on a
kid you put some clothes on a kid like a
kid doesn't decide what they wear they
don't have to make any decisions just
put a [ __ ] mask that's fine i didn't
realize that like
they don't like wearing it and can't
articulate why like imagine your kid
going
it's hard for me to breathe i can't
breathe and then you're forcing a man i
can't breathe and you see the mask going
into their mouth as they take deep
breaths out of them that's [ __ ]
terrifying for a parent yeah you know so
now i get it completely i don't think
it's some like crazy right wing
like a almost like a talking point like
you use the k kids for more sympathy i
truly think it's parents going dude my
kid does not like wearing it he feels
[ __ ] uncomfortable
what are we going to do about this i
just can't yeah we're doing this to
protect unvaccinated people because
they're the ones at the highest risk of
dying if you don't want to get the
vaccine don't but if a kid kills you ah
yeah you shouldn't have to wear the mask
because you don't want to get the
vaccine and why are you around why are
you around my kid yeah creep what are
you doing around my kid [ __ ] creep do
you work at the school well the school
probably mandates that you have that
yeah and that's their right but not
yours you creep yeah why are you around
my kid get out of here
that's a good point why are you near my
kid
why is anybody near my kid i need to
have a kid say again you don't even have
a kid i might and somebody could be near
him
yeah just stay six feet from my kid how
about that i'm not gonna put a mask on
my kid for that reason
uh you want to [ __ ] my kid and not get
cold
you can't have it your way yeah you
can't have your kid need it too yeah
[Applause]
you